maryanne kochiya breaks her silence  following rumors she had an affair with  Brad Pitt the pair star in the upcoming  World War Two drama allied and  allegations of an on-set affair quickly  swirled after news broke angelina  jolie's split from Pitt a source told et  the rumors were not true and on  Wednesday Marianne shut down the reports  herself in a lengthy Instagram caption  she even revealed she is pregnant  firstly many years ago I met the man of  my life father of our son and of the  baby we are expecting he is my love my  best friend the only one that I need the  oscar winner has been married to french  actor guild kanay since 2007 in her post  Marian also wished Brad and Angie well  riding I do very wish that Angelina and  Brad both whom I deeply respect will  find peace in this very tumultuous  moment she added quote and to all the  media and the haters who are quick to  pass judgment I sincerely wish you a  speedy recovery  you